c'est lors de votre édito alexis bonsoir
emmanuel macron qui donc est en visite
dans le nord demain puis d'autres
déplacements de prévu un président
clairement campagne sur le terrain mais
en tout cas quelle est sa fenêtre de tir
pour sa candidature c'est un petit peu à
la question tout le monde se pose
oui c'est sûr alors emmanuel macron ça
rime avec caméléon demain il est sur les
terres du nord pour se recueillir sur
les mines les mineurs bien sûr alors que
sa politique a bénéficié aux plus riches
depuis cinq ans mais il n'est pas à une
contradiction près et d'ailleurs avec
ses nombreux costumes qu'il a pu
endosser il endosse à la fois le costume
de président et il a du mal à choisir
celui de candidat c'est vrai d'autres
déplacements sont encore prévues même si
tout est flou dans l'agenda présidentiel
donc on attend de savoir comment et
quand mêmes macron va se déclarer
candidat lui souhaite le faire d'une
manière assez désinvolte pour ne pas
officialiser finalement sa candidature
et garder une stature présidentielle qui
est tout à fait dans son intérêt il est
à la fois prises dans la réplique
française président aussi de l'union
européenne pendant quelques mois ci qui
fait qu'il est au dessus de la mêlée
d'une certaine façon d'ailleurs ses
porte paroles comme gabriel at-elle on
dit que il n'y avait aucune raison pour
qu'ils évoluent mâcon participent à un
débat du premier tour c'est étonnant
quand même pour un candidat sortant qui
souhaitent sa réélection d'autres
candidats ont joué la carte et la montre
c'était le cas de jacques chirac de
nicolas sarkozy aussi de faire des
campagnes éclair parce que ça permet
d'aller vite d'éviter aussi de défendre
son bilan trop long trop longuement
parce que comme je le disais ce bilan
finalement bien ils ne bénéficient pas
de à tous les français loin de là alors
au delà du timing de l'annoncé qui ne
fait plus aucun doute quel bilan à
défendre
alexis pour emmanuel macron parce qu'il
est des sondages des non satisfait le
chômage des jeunes sacrifiés 300 landu
de kovy pas vraiment de réforme de
retraites le pouvoir d'achat qui qui
grince bon bref c'est pas très joyeux
pour l'instant il ya des choses à
défendre mais c'est ce qui est compliqué
alors et ils défendent l e sculpture
formidable c'est vrai c'est une bonne
mesure mais si on regarde en détail ce
quinquennat c'est un échec un échec à la
fois économique on a les chiffres du
chômage qui sont à peu près les mêmes
qu'en 2012 au moment où françois
hollande a tenté la version de la courbe
du chômage on a une croissance à -1 1%
même si tout le monde dit qu'on est à +
7 % en réalité on rattrape le choc qu'a
été le confinement du coc vides et les
moins 8% de croissance on a une dette
faramineuse la dette qu'ovide là aussi
comment la rembourser ça va être très
compliqué et puis on a 300 morts du coït
par jour et menait macron veut les faire
oublier avec le pass vaccinale et dire
que finalement au micron c'est un petit
virus c'est qu'on va continuer de vivre
comme avant surtout surtout ne pas
mentionner le nombre de morts quotidiens
du coc vide ou avec le co vide et puis
il y à tous les déçus de la politique
macro nist pendant cinq ans 67% des
français qui s'estiment perdants des
politiques mises en place par abonné le
maquereau c'est le dernier sondage ifop
fiducial
ils étaient 73 % il ya de ça quelques
mois et on voit bien que le pouvoir
d'achat est bien il a stagné voire il a
diminué pour de nombreux français malgré
l'échec énergie malgré les petits
cadeaux pour essayer de gagner des
élections que fait madame macron depuis
des semaines il fait des cadeaux des
promesses des chèques en blanc avec
l'argent des français pour finalement
assurer une réélection avec cet argent
parce que lui en tant que président peut
se permettre ces largesses la réalité
c'est un pays endetté c'est un pays qui
ne sait pas finalement si l'économie va
se relever de ses politique délétère
face au co vide et c'est un président
qui a fait gagner les plus riches des
français est certainement pas tous les
français donc aujourd'hui ça me paraît
un bilan difficilement défendable y
compris pour ses fans de la première
heure parce qu'il était celui qui
apportait les réformes la réforme des
retraites elle n'a pas eu lieu il ya eu
la réforme de l'assurance-chômage poussé
in fine et par la ministre du travail
mais on voit qu emmanuel macron qui
promettait un nouveau monde finalement a
fait le pire de l'ancien monde avec des
conflits d'intérêts à la chaîne des
mises en examen finalement un monde
politique aussi délétère que celui
d'avant on a l'impression que c'est un
échec et pourtant tous ceux présents
pour lui de la meilleure des façons avec
des médias qui le pousse dans les
sondages heureusement que c'est le
meilleur président que la france ait
jamais connu loin s'en fout alors avec
aa laissez le en même temps cher est
manuelle macron n'était pas aidé par les
divisions des camps de droite et de
gauche quand même alors c'est vrai qu'il
y a une chose qui facilite la campagne
non encore officiels déballer le
maquereau c'est la division des camps en
présence que ce soit le camp de gauche
avec une nouvelle candidate qui vient
d'arriver christiane taubira bravo à
elle mais ça fait beaucoup de candidats
à gauche et le camp de droite divisée
entre valérie pécresse les républicains
eric zemmour et marine le pen trois
candidats aussi sur un segment qu'ils
pourraient se regrouper lui emmanuel
macron a la chance d'être au centre et
d'obtenir ce centre de manière
hégémonique même si edouard philippe
attend son heure avec horizons avec
cette maison commune qui va transformer
en marche un nouveau mouvement avec vous
cinquante plus tout est fait pour
effacer le nom en marche pour effacer le
nom est menée macron pour effacer le
bilan finalement et faire en sorte que
ce président caméléon comme je le disais
en introduction peut continuer va
continuer à être le tenant finalement de
ce camp du centre qui peut faire tout et
n'importe quoi y compris des politiques
liberticides où les devoirs sont
supérieurs aux droits ou le pass
vaccinale anticonstitutionnel est imposé
aux français où les étudiants ont été
obligés de faire la queue pour se
nourrir devant les banque alimentaire
alors que l'iss se gargarise finalement
de sa politique sur le pass culture et
quelques détails technocratique mais la
réalité de ce quinquennat de cinq ans
c'est une division des français comme
jamais c'est un pays fracturée c'est un
pays aussi inquiets avec des suscite
chez les jeunes comme on en a jamais vu
avec des français aussi qui en ont marre
de cette politique ou et melba kron veux
emmerder une portion de la population
jusqu'au bout je crois que pour lui
cette candidature est pourquoi il l'a
recul c'est que finalement il sera face
à un miroir et face à ce miroir c'est le
vote des français et peut-être que là il
aura du mal à changer de costume et
c'est l édito d'alexis poulain merci
avoue alexis